والى كوريا الجنوبيه وصلت تحرك الصيني
ليطرق باب المعارضه في سول هذه المره
السفير الصيني هناك حذر من اعتماد كوريا
الجنوبيه على
رهانات خاطئه في التنفس الصيني الامريكي
وحتى سؤال على وقف ما وصفه بالانفصال
واستعاده العلاقات الاقتصاديه
والدبلوماسيه معها تصريحات السفير الصيني
جاءت خلال لقاء جمعه برئيس حزب المعارضه
الرئيسيه في البلاد والذي انتقد بدوره
اتباع بلاده لدبلوماسيه غير متوازنه تجاه
التحالف الامريكي على حساب العلاقات مع
الصين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات